rejettent également des polluants nocifs
qui menacent notre santé là, maintenant.
Tout ce temps, je m'étais concentré sur les risques environnementaux à long terme
alors que j'aurais dû m'insurger
contre les effets immédiats sur la santé de ces polluants dans l'air.
La pollution est une grave crise de santé publique.
Elle tue sept millions de personnes par an,
coûte cinq mille milliards de dollars à l'économie mondiale
et, pire encore, nous dérobe notre bien le plus précieux,
notre espérance de vie :
elle a baissé de six mois dans ma ville natale, Paris,
et jusqu'à 3, 4, 5 ans dans certaines régions de l'Inde et de la Chine.
Aux États-Unis, les gaz d'échappement tuent plus que les accidents de la route.
Alors comment se protéger de la pollution ?
A cause d'un manque d'informations, c'est difficile.
On a trop peu de données pour comprendre notre exposition.
Et c'est parce que la façon dont nous mesurons la qualité de l'air aujourd'hui
n'est pas faite pour nous aider à respirer mais aider les gouvernements à gouverner.
Par des réseaux de stations de surveillance de la qualité de l'air,
comme celle-ci à Londres,
les villes décident quand couper le trafic ou fermer des usines.
Et ces machines sont comme les ordinateurs des années 60
qui étaient gigantesques.
Ils sont très précis, mais tellement grands,
lourds, coûteux -
que seuls quelques-uns d'entre eux peuvent être déployés
et ils ne sont pas mobiles.
Les gouvernements voient ainsi la pollution de l'air
mais pour nous,
la qualité de l'air ressemble à ça.
Elle change tout le temps :
d'heure en heure, de rue en rue,
jusqu'à huit fois au sein d'un seul pâté de maisons.
Et même d'intérieur à extérieur.
alors à moins de marcher le long d'une de ces stations,
ils ne peuvent pas savoir ce qu'on respire.
Que serait la protection environnementale
si elle se mettait à l'heure du smartphone ?
Ces trois dernières années,
mon équipe et moi avons construit une technologie
capable de dire ce que vous respirez
et elle tient dans la main.
Flow est un traqueur de qualité de l'air que vous pouvez mettre
sur votre sac à dos, vélo, poussette.
Il comporte des mini capteurs
qui enregistrent les plus gros polluants de l'air autour de vous,
comme les oxydes d'azote,
les gaz d'échappement,
ou des particules qui pénètrent votre circulation sanguine
et causent AVC ou problèmes cardiaques.
Ou encore les composés organiques volants,
les produits chimiques du quotidien,
qu'on finit par respirer.
Flow rend ces données exploitables
et vous aide à comprendre ce que vous respirez
en vous disant où et quand vous avez été exposé,
et de prendre des décisions en connaissance de cause
pour agir contre la pollution.
Changer ses produits à la maison,
emprunter le meilleur itinéraire à vélo,
courir quand la pollution n'a pas atteint son pic,
trouver le meilleur parc où aller avec les enfants...
Tout ça permet de prendre de meilleures habitudes et d'être moins exposé
et en surveillant la qualité autour d'eux,
les cyclistes, les parents
contribuent aussi au traçage de la qualité de l'air.
Flow est donc plus qu'un appareil :
c'est une communauté.
L'été dernier,
nous avons envoyé des prototypes à 100 volontaires à Londres,
et ils ont cartographié la qualité de l'air ensemble,
sur 1 600 km de trottoirs,
et ont couvert 20% du centre de Londres.
Notre objectif est de le faire connaître au monde entier,
que la foule nous fournissent des données pour cartographier chaque rue,
construire une base de données sans précédent
pour que les scientifiques étudient la pollution
et pour permettent aux citoyens et aux décideurs politiques,
de soutenir l'assainissement de l'air.
Parce que ça peut et doit changer.
A l'époque des cigarettes dans les bars,
il a fallu des décennies de recherche sur le cancer du poumon et le tabagisme passif
pour finalement voir arriver des lois interdisant de fumer.
On doit, et on va voir arriver ce même moment pour la qualité de l'air.
Rien que ces deux dernières années,
on a vu des taxes records sur les constructeurs
trichant sur les normes d'émission.
En ville, ce sont des taxes d'encombrement ou des pistes cyclables -
Paris a transformé cette autoroute
juste à côté de chez moi, au centre-ville,
en parc au bord de l'eau.
Et maintenant, les maires du monde entier veulent interdire le diesel
d'ici 2025, 2030, 2035.
Mais pouvons-nous aller plus vite, comment sauver plus de gens ?
La technologie ne résoudra pas le problème du changement climatique,
et ne fera pas disparaître la pollution du jour au lendemain.
Mais elle peut rendre la qualité de l'air plus transparente,
et si nous aidons les gens
à passer à l'action pour améliorer leur santé,
alors ensemble, nous pouvons agir pour mettre fin à la pollution.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)